Women are looked at in a different way.
Nobody expect them being
soldiers, fighting, being spies.
When you go into a place, for instance,
where everybody knows each other,
and you are supposed
to collect information,
when a guy goes into a place like that,
straight away, people will
start looking suspiciously.
Women can do the same thing
and people might look at them,
but will not think that
they're doing something
that they're not supposed to.
That's the difference.
And women can use that.
Women come to me and say to me,
"I always dreamed of being a spy.
I've always dreamed to
be somebody like you."
I look at them and I say, "You know what?
It's not what you think it is
because it's a lot of
moments of being in places
that you don't really want to be at.
Like when you watch
somebody, day and night,
you just sit and watch.
It's not easy. It's not fabulous.
It's not a fantasy.
You can find yourself in weird
place, doing weird things.
And all you want is to go back
home, to be with your kids."
Women see things and remember details.
One of the first jobs that I
did, I was supposed to wait
for a woman coming off a bus.
I didn't know who she
was. I never had a name.
She was a very pretty girl.
With her was a guy much older than her.
And you follow people at their back.
So you see their backs most of the time.
At one stage, the guy
and the woman stopped
underneath the lights of the street.
The guy took out a pipe,
lit his pipe, and continued walking.
And they went into where we
thought they were going to.
So we thought the job was finished.
That evening, I was told
that I was supposed to go
to the airport to pass that woman
to another group of people.
I said easy enough, okay, let's go.
Went to the airport.
And I looked at this couple
who looked very similar
to what I remembered, but
it was a big difference.
He was much older
and she, she wasn't as pretty,
her face wasn't smooth,
it had pimples on it.
'Cause when I saw her, you
know, the light wasn't strong.
She looked so beautiful.
But in real life, she
was completely different,
and he was too.
Nobody else had come.
So I said to the guy
next to me, I said, "Look
I think it's those two.
But to make sure that they are,
if the guy takes his pipe out,"
and I explained to him how
the pipe looked exactly,
"then you know it's them."
Thank God it was.
He took out the pipe, job done.
And I remembered it for some reason.
I didn't tell myself,
"Oh, look at this pipe.
Remember what it looks like."
It just goes through your
head and you remember,
so women see these details,
we remember these details and
information that men don't.
When I started, I was very young, 21.
I was a shy girl from a small village.
I wasn't educated.
I didn't do much with my life.
And I learned how to think.
And I learned how to judge people.
And I learned how to look at things
and to be broad-minded.
You become a different person.
And that's who I became.
And that's who I am today.
I think differently.
It gave me a lot of security
in myself and who I am.
I'm proud.
I used to, I wasn't like that.
I'm proud of who I am.
If you're a spy and you hear what I say,
you know and understand me
much better than all the rest.
After I quit my job as a
spy, I took time to heal
because you give up a lot of your life.
As a wife, as a mother, and
you have to heal the family,
and you have to heal yourself
to become a normal person again.